hi
my name is kara everly and i voice wise
and ruby
i'm kathleen zelch and i voice text on
redwood blue and glenda on all of them
stand for different characters there's
four main characters
r is ruby which is red w is wise which
is who i voice
the color is white and we have b which
stands for black
and her name is blake and we have y for
yang
and she's yellow it's honestly awesome i
mean our fan reaction has been
absolutely insane i mean it's
it's more than anybody could have really
ever imagined and it's just so great and
so awesome and i feel
so grateful to be a part of something
like this we're excited to have a new
demographic to
uh rooster t's viewership uh it's a lot
more female
based but traditional fans of red versus
blue are embracing it as well so it's
great
it's a good role model type show and not
only that i mean even our even our male
fans love it i mean who doesn't love you
know for badass girls right we're not
showing that it's not the tits and ass
kind of
anime it's more story driven and
a little bit more uh taste as far as
costuming and you know there's
definitely a lot of thought that goes
into it
for sure well you know that the creator
monty young actually
knew the voice actresses from our office
and kind of pictured who they would work
best for the show
so uh it was never even a question of
going to that whole familiar
anime kind of kitty style he's
definitely put
some of the actual voice actresses some
of their some of our characteristics
into the characters that we play that
way you know it's a little bit easier
for us not only to get the emotion out
through our boys
but it's also you know very similar to
how we are in real life so people can
relate to them really easily
rubies are going to be airing on
thursday nights 5 pm for sponsors at
central time and 7 p.m
for the general public on
roosterteeth.com